ضحكة روز البريئة عندما
تصل عائلتها إلى
مصر، أختها التي ولدت في غزة أثناء
الحرب كانت صغيرة جدًا بحيث لا تستطيع استيعاب الفظائع
في وطنها، وقد بُترت ساق والدتها ران م
قبل أيام قليلة من
ولادتها، وتقول إنهم
نجوا بأعجوبة عندما أصاب صاروخ منزلهم.
home
spe
كان من الممكن إنقاذ ساق ران لكن
الأطباء كانوا غارقين في
إصابات أكثر خطورة كعائلة
فقدوا كل شيء ولكن
حياتهم العشرات من غزة يصلون إلى
معبر رفح بإصابات خطيرة لا
يتمكن الجميع من النجاة أحيانًا يعودون إلى منازلهم
في
أكياس الجثث في الصف الخامس  يتعلم ياهر
لعب لعبة المونوبولي المصرية وهو يتعافى
من كسر في ساقه وكسر في
الجمجمة،
ولا يعرف بعد أن والديه قد قُتلا. وقد
أعادت سيارات الإسعاف المصرية هذه التي تعبر من رفح إلى غزة ما يقرب من 400
مصاب بجروح خطيرة لتلقي العلاج  في
المستشفيات المصرية، مئات الشاحنات على
الجانب المصري من
المعبر الأكثر وعورة في انتظار التصريح لتوصيل
المساعدات التي تشتد الحاجة إليها إلى غزة قبل ساعات من
انتهاء الهدنة التي سمحت لنحو 200
شاحنة بالدخول يوميًا، حتى مع السلطة الفلسطينية
والقتال، للحصول على الغذاء والوقود والماء
والأدوية والملابس.  كانت عملية الدخول إلى غزة عملية
شاقة بعد مغادرة مصر، حيث
مروا عبر فحص أمني إسرائيلي
عند معبر نيتسانا
يقول السائقون إن الأمر قد يستغرق ما يصل إلى 3 أيام للحصول على
تصريح. قام محمود بالرحلة مرتين
وينتظر في الطابور لتوصيل طلبيته الثالثة
ولكن  في مطار إيليش بمصر،
تتدفق كميات كبيرة من التبرعات
ليلًا ونهارًا لتحويل هذه
المنشأة العسكرية إلى مركز إنساني، وقد
رأينا للتو طائرة النقل العسكري القبرصية
قادمة عندما وصلنا إلى هنا، كانت هناك
طائرة من سنغافورة وطائرة أخرى من
الاتحاد الأوروبي تجلب جميعها  في
المساعدات الأساسية باعتبارها أكبر
إمدادات إنسانية في العالم
لغزة، تقول الأمم المتحدة إن كل هذا لا يزال مجرد
قطرة في محيط، ومع
عدم اليقين بشأن الحقيقة، بالكاد يحدث أي شيء
في لاري موو سي إن إن رافا
مصر